Hey Guys How's It going it'S justine and Today we're doing an #AskiJ That's ask iJustine for short so i asked
You Guys on twitter for some questions and most of the questions we're about the new iPhone
We are Nearing
September 12th, like i am counting down the Days I Feel like Every one of Those Advent Calendars like The countdown to christmas but this is
Like The Countdown to my Christmas and That's iPhone Announced in a day so it's officially happening on September 12th Which i'm Extremely
Excited About If You can't tell It I'm not slurring My Speech
I'm
Slobbering All Over Myself I'm a Freaking Mess Let's get into the first iPhone question that i have these are not all gonna be?
- questions Just The first few so stay Tuned Monisha Wants to know if It Would Be Better to get the iphone 7s or the
iPhone 8 There's in so many different Rumors There's gonna be an iphone
7s there's gonna Be iphone 7s plus there's going to be an iPhone 8 Which may be called The iphone in Addition or there might Be an
Iphone Pro we don't Know Here's the Thing the iPhone or whatever?
That Version of The New Phone is going to be They'll probably be one of the most Expensive Phones to date basically an All-Over
Upgraded Phone and V7s is going to be a slight upgrade over The 7 Whereas the iPhone 8 will have the new vertical
Camera Will have The larger storage Oled Screen
Potentially Usb See charging Instead of the lightning and i answer your question What did you even Ask me oh i feel like for a
Lot of People Looks gonna Depend on the price point how much do you want
To spend on this Phone so basically
That's What i asked you how much is too much to spend for the new iPhone Frank the take is asking Black or White iPhone
I mean it's looking Like most of The rumors are the black the white and the copper color i'm probably gonna do the White version
I've Been super into the black and i don't know
Oh gosh i'm not sure i don't think i'm gonna Get the copper i'll probably get it Just
To make a video of It but something the drive doesn't be Kind of Crazy and i've Said that so many Times before is That
I always have a case on My Phone Because i Am App Hazard i am so unable to
Hold a Phone in my Hands Without dropping It and so i hate being Able to see the color of My Phone unless the case
Matches It Perfectly
Granted This is Black and White But That's sort of a Theme That I'm going for and again i might Go for the black Phone
Because The camera is Black Which would then show the White here and then if i do
A minute to get back to you because i'm having a Lot of internal conflict Right Now and i'd Rather not have that on camera
What Features are you Looking Forward to most in the next Phone so there's gonna be a lot of cool things that I'm super Excited
To check Out i've also Been using Ios 11 for a Few months Now and i absolutely love It so Usually When you get Your
New Phone Loved the biggest Shocking Things is the ios is completely different so for me That's not going to be that different but it
Will Be Exciting to see how they integrate Ios 11 without the touch id oh Boy
I'm Wondering if People are going to like That
Or if They're not gonna like It i'm used to it only Because i've Been using My Samsung Phone and the pixel Phone
Previously we'll See how the iphone users Kind of Adapt to not having the touch id button it's something that we've all Been so used
To having for so long Well That's about it for the iphone questions
Kristine is asking What'S the last Thing that i watched on netflix and i have Watched?
so much netflix in the past
Month Usually in the summer Things Kind of tend to slow down in the Whole YouTube and entertainment World a Lot of People are traveling
a lot of People are on Vacation
and Doing This or that so i decided i'm gonna Watch netflix and i'm gonna focus and i'm gonna Watch It much met Flicks as
Possible While still
Sort of Maintaining Some sort of social life and my YouTube Channel i watched all of That oh Jay Simpson show that Was on Fx
Or Was at showtime or something all of It in like Two Days
So good and after that i watched three seasons of American crime and then i watched ozar and then i watched more
Chela and There's a Few Other Things that i watched in between that but most Recently This past week i watched
Daredevil oh i watched Defenders That's Why i started Watching Daredevil Because i had Seen Luke cage and Watch Iron fist and a Lot of
People Didn't Like Iron fist but i really Really Really Liked Iron fist Leave me some comments Below if anybody else Like That Show
Too cuz i really Enjoy It and also i don't want
To make Any of The comic People Mad i have never Read a Comic in My life so i'm Just gonna be completely Honest With
You i don't know the differences between the comics and the shows and the comics and the Movies i love
Superhero Movies I'm a Huge Fan of Marvel so i've Been Really enjoying everything That Marvel has Been putting out on netflix
more specifically Love The Defenders That Was the last Thing that i watched and then i was like shoot i
Never Finished Daredevil so i finished all of Daredevils
Yesterday I Just started on
Season 2 Today and from that I'm Excited Because They also announced that the punisher is gonna be out this fall Which
Yes Sign me Up i'll be there i will be bending that Day One of The release Anyway What Was i talking about
describe Your dog in one Word Perfect
he is a
Perfect prince
When Am i gonna upload some Stuff on my gaming Channel i don't think i'll ever upload anything on My gaming Channel anymore This is
My Main Channel if I'M going to be posting any Gameplay it'll probably Be Here running several Channels by Myself It Was not fun i
Didn't Enjoy it It was so stressful i was always worried about oh my gosh i have to post two or three gaming videos a
Day Which Would then take Away from my main Channel Which Was my main Channel and my Main focus then Basically everything
Suffered My video Suffered You Suffered i Was suffering Because i was putting Myself Through This
abusive Cycle of Shadows more Videos Got Those four videos you got a post more videos and i Was like
Hold on a Second My Gaming Channel
Basically Ruined Gaming For me because it wasn't fun anymore It was for a Few Years and that Just became like a chore so since
I've stopped My gaming Channel i have Enjoyed Playing Games Again i can Just Sit Crappy posture
Snack Drink My Coffees in My Garamantes
Feet Up enjoying My game to myself and not have to entertain or talk to anyone That's the way gaming Should be
So many products of People Who could do live streams Like i Just
Man can't i don't want to entertain i Just want to sit for me gaming has always Been an outlet sort of Take me out
Of Whatever World That I'm Currently in and Put me into another one to take my Mind off of Things so yeah
That Was a Long Story Short or Was It a short Story long Hmm next question
Sorry My camera Died I'm Better he wants to know who i'm gonna mane in destiny and at The time of making This destiny Is
Not out yet It Will be Out Today I'm Shooting This on Tuesday so tonight is the night and my Plan Is
To probably Mean As a Hunter That's What i played on the first one so we'll see i'm not sure i haven't really decided yet
But You can bet When i do post It Which i probably already Have posted It on Twitter or instagram?
Story You can Check it Out there for an update i'm so Excited for destiny me and My Sister Plan on Playing a
Lot We Played So much Destiny One When it first came Out and then It sort of fell off for Us so i'm hoping That
This Is one of Those Games that i
Still Enjoy Playing for a long time so i'm thinking that My Plan for gaming the next few months Is gonna be play Destiny
Until Mario Comes Out and then I'm gonna Play Mario Until Call of Duty comes Out and then i'll Play Call of Duty for a
Little While and if i Haven't Finished Mario i'll Go back and Play That and then Kind of Intermixed Destiny Mario and Call of Duty
Within
Whatever Timeframe i have What i like about Call of Duty is Just Playing Simple multiplayer Matches Like There's no Thoughts i don't
Have to think i Just Kind of Turn on the game and i'm Just like
investing Equally it's gonna be a Long-term commitment
Whereas Mario I'M Just gonna Play Until completion and Then That's that did i answer your question i don't wants to know what my favorite
false Snack is pumpkin Bread i love pumpkin Bread so much i love pumpkin Bread in the morning in the night in the evening in
The day and the Whenever as a Snack it's for dinner for Lunch Whatever man Pumpkin Bread Is so good oh?
Jordan Let's Know if i Play Pc Games
And i guess i sort of do i Mean i definitely don't Play as much as i used to i've Played Minecraft on the Pc
And The last piece of game that i had Played It Was overwatch Which i chose to play on PC because most of my Friends
Playing Overwatch Played on Pc and how i decide usually When i play Games is where are my friends at so if my Friends are
Playing a Game on Xbox I'm gonna Play There if They're Playing on Playstation i'll Play There i'm Playing on PC i'll Play There as
Well i think That's
Pretty Much
yeah i think That's it
Actually those are all of our questions that we Have for Today Thank you so much for watching if you guys Have any questions you?
Can Feel free to leave those in the comments Below and i will answer them by typing back to you like a rule
Something i was gonna Say Analog That's not analog it's still digital Doesn't Say it's really Basic but it's not That basic i don't know
I'm not sure i had a lot of caffeine Today so
I'm gonna get o and drink some water to calm Down from all the caffeine and the excitement that Games are coming Out time to
Flight Oh i'll see you Later i
Love The Holiday Season i don't know
you